上课啊，同学们。
咱们今天讲一个呃。
挺敏感，但是很实用的话题。
啥话题呢？
就是关于。
关于烂片。
我犹豫了一下，然我要写这个烂字，因为这么一写这个这个词儿就有点重。
或者我们叫他。
不太好看的那些片吧。
讲这个话题显然很敏感，为啥呢？你一举例子就得罪人。
是不是？
谁也不愿意听。
但是很实用，为什么呢？因为。
咱们的同学啊。
从这种片子里面，反而能学到更多的东西。
因为他们犯了错你也会犯。
他们能遇到的问题你也能遇到。
千万不要简简单单归结说哎呀，辣米片就是那些人水平不行。
咱别这么去想问题。
能够拍片，能够操操盘大项目。
个个都是人精。
对吧。
他们为什么拍出烂片？
肯定是有原因的。
我们从中能学到很多东西的。
所以这一节课。
我就算顶着压力，对吧？给大家讲一讲。
话题讲讲这。
我们先。
找一个案例。
然后呢，大家一起看看这个案例。
找一找他的问题。
以及为什么会有这些问题。
还有这些问题的解决方案，以及我们如果以后遇到这样的项目，我们应该怎么做？
方方面面吧，一用一个呃不太好看的片子。
作为案例，我们大家争取学点东西。
这一节课呢会很实用，大家认真听好吧。
我找个片子。
战过。
战国这个片子啊。
挺符合这个咱们这一课的主题的。
他曾经长期霸占。
各大评分榜。
倒数第一的宝座。
嗯。
很长一段时间，我在我印象当中，他都是倒数第一。当然现在现在出了更低的，好像。
但我们还是讲它吧，为什么呢？
第一这个片子有点年头了。
包括主创人员相信也应该。
承认这个片子没拍好这个事实了。
再加上这个片子的主角呢。
是红雷哥红雷哥跟我。
关系挺好。
我就拿自己人开刀，这样的话是吧？
不至于得罪人不至于得罪人。因为生活生活里面火雷哥还是一个。
很nice很温柔。
甚至有点内向的一个人啊，并不像荧幕上的那种形象。
很好相处。所以。
咱就得罪他吧，是吧？
咱俩站不过。
然后。
呃，我这几天。
我其实是两天前跟班委会商量。
决定讲这个主题的这一课讲这个主题的。
所以我就找了这个片子。
因为我以前看过这个片子，实在是看不下去，所以没看完。
我要讲，那我必须把它看完。
我这几天真的是很尴尬，就是顶着尴尬症。
花了好几段时间把片子看完。
确实是不好看。
确实是可以。
拿出来跟大家好好讲一讲。我相信很多同学可能也没看过，所以我们准备了一个。
呃，在在网上找了一个那种速看电影，大家先有个基本的认知，大家先看一下。
要我吗？
西奇末。
并当然不远与之搏斗。
兽落荒而逃。
伤。
立刻放了天老将军军上盛名。
天下贤士幸亏我大齐，我其人有幸。
清清吗？
好好在水里清醒清醒吧。
惨暴。
我说让迪卢什么时候叫，他就会什么时候叫你姓信不信，那他要是真叫了怎么办呢？
想怎么办就怎么办？如果是真叫让眼睛。
祝好。
先生不知。
是。
先生不说。
我也不是。
献上皆石。
谢美。
今夜估叫就成全你。
只要答应我。
此战无论胜败。
啊。
就是这个战国。
这个故事讲的是啥呢？
我跟同学们说啊。
好的电影啊，我们以前啊经常讲一些好电影的案例的时候，好电影特别容易用一两句话给你讲清楚。
越是好的电影，他越可以用一两句话给你讲清楚。
明白这个意思吧？就是它的细壳啊很干净。
很厉害，很能打，很简洁。
但是像不太好看的片子呢，一两句话就讲不清楚，因为你也不知道他在说什么。
这个故事呢。
我尽量的先给大家复盘一下啊。
尽量先给大家复盘一下。
呃，我们就用戏中的角色，因为它是个历史剧，所以我们就用戏中角色的名字啊。首先男女主是这个。
孙膑。
和。
前夕孙膑就是红雷哥那角色。
田西呢就是景田那个角色，其实田西的。
戏份是最多的，它更像视角。
然后呢，以孙膑历史上记载的几个故事为依据。
用。
孙膑和田希的爱情线。
讲的这么一个故事。所以它本质上呢。
是一个爱情家。
就这个片子它在叙事。
类型上是一个爱情片，它是一个爱情故事的结构，讲的是他俩的。
相识相知，相爱，然后分离。
指爱情片的结构，他用的是爱情片的结构。
然后其他的角色呢像跟孙膑斗的。
那个人叫。
叫庞娟，就是吴振宇那个角色。
然后呢。
唐娟有个妹妹叫。
叫什么叫跑瓦。
就是惊喜战这个角色。
欣喜善的一个角色，然后田希跟庞婉呢是姐妹儿。
然后就好就有闺蜜。
然后呢，田西是田记的。
田季的女儿。
田忌呢就是那个历史上那个那个大将军，对吧？那个那个武将姜武姜武演的。
就是这么一个人人员构成吧。
然后呢，这帮人呢隶属于魏国。
然后呢，这帮人呢隶属于齐国。
就基本上就是这么一个。
呃，世界构建，然后以爱情片为故事结构为依据。
讲孙膑跟田夕之间的爱情就是这样一个片子。
这个片子呢我刚才说了，我花了好几天时间才看完。
当然因为要讲，所以我看了三遍啊，你们也知道老师付出了多少，确实很痛苦，真的很痛苦。
这个故事写的真的真的是不好，真的是不好，整个完成。
出来的成品呈现来讲真的是。
不是很好的片子。
在这里我们首先强调一下啊。
咱们的同学一定要有一个学习的态度。
这个面对这样的片子呢，我们也可以学到东西。
首先我们得有几个认知。第一。
一个烂片是怎么产生的？
一个烂片是怎么产生的？我们要。
我们说市场上这么多不好的片子，他们都是怎么产生的？
肯定不是那些人傻。我首先告诉你这一点。
对吧我们千万不要有这种认知，觉得阿盖是因为他们傻，他们不如我们，对吧？
呃。
绝对不是这样的。
很多片子。
我这么说吧。
凡是从业时间够长的从业者。
谁都拍过烂片。
谁也别装都一样，大家都拍过烂片，对吧？所以心里应该有点数。
烂片一般是怎么产生的？
我觉得。
我觉得啊。
一般是两大方面的原因导致片子最后很烂。第一就是这个片子从根儿上，从骨子里他就没打算。
他就不是以拍一个好片为主要目的了。
这个你们从业了之后，你们会去遇到这种情况了，就是说不是每次拍片子。
第一目的都是为了拍一个好片。
会有很多。
比如说资本层面或者金融层面，甚至是权力层面的一些考量。
干扰了这个主线目标。就是说这个片子本身它这个产品生产的时候，它最主要的目标不是好看。
这个占很大的一部分原因。
明白吗？就我们观众一厢情愿的认为。
这是他应该好看。但是在生产过程中，因为。
情况很复杂，他不是。
混着好看。
去的或者第一目标不成。
当然了，他完成他的第一目标顺带好看，他也愿意。但是有时候为了完成第一目标，这个就牺牲了。
这是一大方面的原因。第一大方面的。
第二大方面的原因是啥啊？
一般就是失控。
因为一个戏生产出来需要好多好多人协作。
像我们拍电视剧的话，一个剧组。
80元。
这就属于最小最小的规模了，对吧？
像大族，那就。
那就没没底儿了，有多少人就没底儿了。你像张艺谋拍长城的时候，他剧组有具体有多少人，我不知道，但他剧组光车有400辆。
你说他得有多少人？
就是说。
非常庞杂的一个系统。
很多很多人写作。
在这个过程中。
出现了失控。
片跟导演不对付了，对吧？然后编剧跟演员互相沟通不了啊。
方方面面的情况配合不上，有时候不是说。
心思不好，是能力不足。
协同不到一起了。
导致项目失控。
那个也是生产烂片的另一大主要原因。
就失控了。
搞不定了。
大家卯不到一块了。
是这个问题。
所以说。
烂片的产生都是有原因的。
我们作为编剧。
我们只看好我们这一台，我们从故事的角度，我们从讲故事的这个角度。
去。
找原因，我们是本着学习的态度去找的，而不是笑话人家说哎呀，你们这这哎这儿都没弄好，那没弄好，我们要知道原因，我们要知道任何人都有可能拍烂片。
我们要知道人家也有人家的苦衷，或者是人家有人家的原因。
明白这意思吧？不是去笑话，好吧，这是第一点我们要认知的。
第二点。
要认知的，我想给同学们好好说的就是。
我们不管是学习也好，还是工作也好。
一定要有一个。
一般毛定。
这个很重要。
这个词儿是我发明的啊，我给大家解释一下啥意思。
就是一般矛盾。
啥叫一般保定呢？就是你不管是学习还是工作。
你的毛病前提就是我是个一般人。
我拥有一般的材料。
一般的能力，我能做出一般的事儿。
就是这是你的前提，这是你的毛病。
因为我发现啊。
很多人喜欢特殊铆钉。
就是上来先铆定我有才。
我跟别人不一样，我能力出众。
我真的是天选之人。
我就应该干大事儿，就有很多年轻人。
有这样的毛病。
甚至一把年纪了，还有这样毛腻的都很多啊。
都很多。
这个毛钉呢。
我认为是不好。
我认为是不好的。
他会影响你。
努力。
影响你。
就是想办法来。
加强自己，想办法把事情做好。
所以我非常推荐大家做一般铆定。
但是呢大部分人做不到，大部分人都喜欢做特生保警。
你知道我咋发现的吗？
因为我做行这么多年啊。
我见过很很多很多的年轻人来找我，因为怀着影视梦的年轻人是很多的啊，这个咱们不怪他，因为确实。
有名有利呀。
怀着影视梦的人很多，所以经常有年轻人跑过来找我跟我说。
还要做编剧。
还要说导演。
或者他要当演员。
他要当歌手，都有来找我的，跟我说这种话。
我给大家复原一下每次的情况。
基本上。
每次一个年轻人来找到我，说老师。
我想当导演。
是吧那我都会不能打击梦想呀，我得先聊一聊。
我就说那你为什么？
觉得自己能当导演或者是你适合当导演。
我得到了回答。
99%都是。
我有才。
对对。
就他觉得他有才，你知道吗？
我说那你具体有什么才？
我真的从小就跟别人不一样。
我有特别特别多的想法，关于故事，关于画面。
然后呢，我每天早晨睡醒，哎呀，我那些想法在我脑子里面像小鸟一样飞过来飞过去，我随便抓住一个就能是一个好作品，我就是这么有才。
同学们相信你们很多人也是这么想。
也是这么想自己的，对不对？
我不是打击你们。
我就是诚实的告诉你们。
每一个年轻人到我这里都是这么说的。
所以这不是彩。
这不叫有才。
这就是。
很一般的一个毛巾，就是你是一个普通人。
你是一个一般人。
你不要觉得我就是天选之人，我死白手，对吧？我我我我不一样，我是不一样的烟火。
好多年轻人都这么想，那么想呢？
就你认为自己特殊。
确实有利于增强你的信心。
但是妨碍你努力，我推荐大家做一般毛顶。
一般锚店就锚店，我是个一般人，我做出来事情呢也可能就很一般。
一般毛病呢会让你努力想办法。
增强自己，加强自己，比别人多付出。我既然是一个般人，那我要做的好，我就得比别人多付出呀，对吧？你能让你努力。
但是啊其实也不影响你的信心。因为我就是一个做一般保定的一个思维。
思维方式为啥不影响你信心呢？因为你是一般毛定，这不光毛定你啊。
那些拍出牛逼大片的人，那些看起来很有才华的作家编剧。
他们也是一般人。
我就是这么矛定的，就我是一般人，但他们也是一般人，他们只不过努力了。
他们只不过有好的方法，然后很努力。
那我如果有好的方法，我也很努力，我也可以。
所以一般矛盾不影响你的信心嘛。
同学们一定啊，就咱们的同学啊一定要把这句话听进去。
以后做一般毛定，不管是学习还是做事儿。
我做一般毛定，从我十六七岁就开始了。我我在这个方面我开窍很早的，我认知很早。
在这里我可以多给大家讲几句。
我是咋开窍的呢？
一般铆定这个事儿。
我十六七岁的时候吧16岁上高一。
上高一的时候。
跟我并排做的。
就跟同桌似的那种并排做的。
有一个男生。
有个男生。
我希望他看不到这堂课。
加钱。
接下来我要开始讲他的故事了。
这个男生呢。
它的外形我给大家描述一下。
他大约是1.6米的身高，作为一个男孩啊，就是挺矮的。
然后呢，身材比例。
不太好。
1.6米的身高，但是头特别大。
特别长。
他的头特别大特别长。
然后呢，身材就整个就比例就特别不好。然后因为这个头特别长。
他获得了很多。
关于。
与与某种动物有关的一些外号。
然后呢。
他这个头呢长成什么样呢？它是那种小卷发，就是那种黄种人特别少见的没有规则的小卷发。
就头只能剃短发，但是呢也支棱了。
就是黑人那种头发。
完全没有。
那个那个规律也没有光泽，就这么卷着。
然后他的眼间距特别开，眼睛很小，眼间距特别开。
就这个特点呢又给他获得了一些。
关于某种两栖动物的外号。
然后呢，再加上我们当时是青春期，16岁嘛。
他满脸的疙瘩。
再加上它又是络腮胡。
等于那个疙瘩叠疙瘩，你知道青石期有那种皮肤啊，就是痤疮。
疙瘩叠了疙瘩，然后好了一批又长一批，等于那胡子也刮不干净，一刮全是血。
我今天把头刮破，还说以，就就是那个皮肤你能想象吗？就是全是疙瘩，然后他加上又是满脸胡子那种。
结果胡子呢也刮不干净，就嵌在那些痘的缝隙里面，坚强的生长，你也刮不到它，对吧？
然后就是这样一个那个那个。
一个大概的形象嘛，就是眼睛的形状也不是很好啊，就是那种最小的那那块。
然后整个五官。
就是全是与与正常审美反的吧，就是鼻子比较塌，然后嘴唇特别薄。
然后就是。
实在是。
然后他耳朵也特别有特点，就是。
小儿招风。
明白这个意思吧？就招风耳不怕，你如果耳朵大也挺好看的，你知道吗？耳朵大有福。
他的耳朵是特别小，但是还立着就小儿招风的耳朵。
就这个男同学他的长相时代来说，我今天就是确实是得罪他了啊。但是我希望他没看到这个课，凭良心说他在长相这个赛道上。
真的是。
绝对是垫底的。
就这样一个同学，他坐我边儿上跟我关系还可以，还不错。
然后有一天上语文课，你知道语文课就是标准开小差的时间，对吧？大家一般语文课本往那一竖里面查一本红楼梦或者是金瓶梅在那看一看，对吧？然后我就看他他也是在那把。
书立者明显书里面藏着东西，然后他就那看。
边看边笑。
就他的脸上洋溢着幸福的微笑，宰像那天是下午的一堂课，你知道吗？阳光还从。
窗外斜洒进来，照在书上和他的脸上，照着他的微笑。
然后他就很幸福的在那微笑。
然后我就很好奇，我操，这小子在看什么书呢？
乐成这样很幸福呀，看着对吧？我得看一看呀，我们俩做隔壁嘛，然后就探头过去一看。
发现他在照镜子。
他的书里面还加了一面小镜子。
然后因为我把头探过去了。
我能听到他嘴里在喃喃自语。
来说。
真帅。
同学们，我能我的反应跟你们一样，我当然是笑了。
但是。
我只笑了，大概不到。
4秒钟。
马上陷入了一个巨大的恐惧之中。
因为我意识到他是真的认为自己很帅。
他完全没有。
客观的一个评价或者一客观的一个锚顶。
那我就想到同样一个问题啊，同学们。
我是不是也是这种情况？
因为我也觉得自己很帅啊。
所以我就陷入了一个巨大的恐惧，我脑子里面就开始拼命的想，我认为自己很帅的依据是什么？
我就在想。
都有谁夸过我帅。
然后迅速的找到了三个案例。
我妈。
我大姨。
我姥姥。
我就慌了，你们知道吧？
我就慌了。
因为我也是真心实意的认为自己很帅。
然后我从那时候开始，我就刻意的观察。
我有没有因为长相得到过好处？
我有没有因因为长相。
出类拔萃过，比如说。
那个那个那个学校拍形象照有没有找过我？
对吧陌生女孩有没有因为你帅来跟你搭话，或者是跟你讲话？
经过我严密的分析。
发现。
他们根本就不帅。
根本就不算。
百变星军里面百变星君那个电影，周星驰不是问梁咏琪吗？
周星驰问梁咏琪说，那你说我到底帅不帅，对吧？
梁雨琪很义正言辞的跟他说。
我宠虫对天发誓。
你根本一点都不帅。
然后周星驰不是马上颓了嘛？
就是这个问题，就是大部分人对自己的毛病啊。
毛定的过高。
不客观。
那因为。
脱这个同学的福，再加上我自己呢又又又又又触类旁通了一下。
所以我发现了这个问题。
同学们一定要注意。
做一番锚定。
就是你做事情啊。
你要清醒的认识你是个一般人。当然你毛盾别人也是一般人，拍出烂片的也是一般。
你也有可能。
当然了，拍出牛逼片子的人也是一般。
你也开可以拍出牛逼的片。
我希望我们同学啊一定要记住这一点，这节课哪怕知识没学到，先把这个学了。
因为我发现这个事情现在愈演愈烈啊。
就对自己的毛病过高，愈演愈烈，导致很多人连对象都找不着。
有时间的话，我再给大家讲个故事，今天得罪人就得罪透了啊。
得罪透了。
大学的时候我大学毕业的时候。
我同学的媳妇儿。
我一个考哥们儿跟我们另外一个大学同学，就等于他俩结婚了。
他俩都是我同学，那女的呢是我们校花。
我们学校校花级的，他俩是我介绍的，所以我们关系都特好。
然后呢，就校花有个闺蜜。
闺蜜。
上过大学的同学都知道啊，你看大学校园里一般一个大美女旁边啊都会跟着一个小矬伴，又又该始得罪人了，怎么回事吧？得罪人，但这是一般规律，我不知道为什么啊，反正就是大学校话级这个姑娘旁边啊，因为大学校园里面女孩。
什么吃饭买东西或者上课，一般都是二人组嘛。
一般都是这么个配置，也不知道为什么，反正就是。
一个像明星一样花枝招展，另外一个像他的经纪人或者助理一样。
又像助理又像保镖吧，就就老是这么一个配。那后这个校花呢，因为它是校花啊，它在容貌上是顶配，所以他配的这个助理呢也是特别典型。
但是这这个笑花跟我哥们儿结婚了嘛，然后呢，他就命令我们俩。
说你们得给我闺蜜介绍个对象，我闺蜜从小到大。
都没有谈过男朋友，都没有动过这根弦儿，对吧？
他他现在我的我结婚了，他很失落，没伴了嘛，没人一块玩的。
你们得给他介绍个对象，这个任务呢就交给我俩。
我俩发现了一个谁的？
就发现了我我哥们儿有一个高中同学跟我们关系也很好。
这个高中同学呢。
也情况跟那个女孩差不多，也是从来没有谈过女朋友，也没动过这根弦儿。
最大的乐趣就是窝在家里打游戏。
然后他长得形象呢。
跟我那个高中同学跟激励我成长那个高中同学，你别说还有点连下，确实有点像。
然后当时我跟我这个同学发现了这一一对人的时候，就是。
我们俩。
不夸张的说，我们俩当时谈贯而庆啊。
就是欢呼啊。
觉得哇天哪解决了哇这。
好了，这个绝配啊。
我们俩当时觉得哇，我们俩都开始庆祝了，提前庆祝了。
觉得这个事儿不妥了，咱俩办了一件漂亮的事儿，对吧？而且这种事又又有功德。
你你对吧又撮合了两个人。
我们俩还的组织饭局和唱歌局。
等于是。
我们俩加上我同学的媳妇儿，再加上这两个当事人，5个人还凑了一局。
介绍他俩认识。
结果大家都能想象得到，对吧？就是这两个当事人分别跟我们俩绝交了。
就是他们俩在吃完这餐饭回去之后。
都发来信息，宣布要跟我们绝交。
我说为什么？
他们俩回的话都一样。
原来我在你们心里就是那样的。
就是原来我在你们心里就是那个档次吗？
就这个问题。
为啥？
就是因为他们对自己的毛病也过高。
所以经过我我发现这个问题之后，我常年研究这个问题啊，我发现啊这个毛病修正啊。
我管这个他们叫自我修正嘛。
做修正基本上是30%。
就30%啊。
就大家对自我的修正30%，就大家对自己的才华认知也好，对自己的相貌、外形认知也好，都有一个差不多30%的自我修正。
真的。
你凡是你去看啊，那种长得不太。
好看的人啊。
比如说长得特别差的人。
假设人的长相比如说是1到10的这么一个区间，那种长得什么三那种就可以特别不好看了。
他也会往上修正个30%。
所以你看那种长得特别不好看的人，他们怎么介绍自己？
他说我这个人吧。
相貌平平。
他觉得自己平行。
然后呢，如果是真的相貌平平，就相貌真的不好，就四分吧。比如说他修正30%之后呢。
他加上30%之后呢，他会觉得我虽然不怎么好看，但是我中等偏上。
你看你生活里面凡是长得不太好的人，他的自我认知都是中等偏少。
就是这个问题。
当然了，我再次强调啊，相貌对于我们的人生没有那么重要。
没有那么重。
但是他是自我认知的一个。
一个比较显性的标尺，让我们能看出来大家对自己。
内在的。
才华也有差不多一个。
修正值的一个错误认知。
这个东西很要命，我为什么花时间讲这个啊？就是这个东西很要命。
同学们不要觉得自己有才。
因为你有没有才华无法验证。
懂吗？我不否认有人有才。
我不否认。
当然有人有才。
但是你无法验证呀，我干这行干这么多年了，我到现在也不知道我自己到底有没有财。
不好说啊，谁知道去。
但是呢你如果对自己做一个一般保病，那你就有努力呗。
那你就实劲努力嘛。
明白这个道理吧，我就花时间讲这个就就就有点耽误时间了啊。我们回到正题啊，说了半天。
题外化。
回到正题说这个战国。
做这个战果。
哎呀，这战国这个片子啊。
看的时候确实很尴尬，包括你看演员表演，你会觉得哎呀。
好像是演员演的很尬。
这个我首先说一下啊。
绝大部分片子最后呈现不好。
其实最不应该怪的。
是演员。
演员最不应该背锅。
为什么呢？是因为演员的演技啊，演员的演技当然有好有坏。当然现在会有一些演员的演技不好。
但是演员的演技绝对不会成为导致一个片子垮掉的原因。
因为大部分从业的演员，他的演技是够用的。
懂这意思吧？他演技是够用。
因为演技啊演员的演技啊，我们可以从两个方面来衡量，一个是爆发力。
爆发力。
一个是控制力。
就是演员的演技啊，一个是爆发力，一个是控制力。
爆发力其实就是他能。
达到的宽度，他最悲伤能伤到哪里，对吧？他最喜欢喜能欢喜到哪里。
咱们大部分人对演技的认知，咱们普通观众对演技的认知往往只是认为是爆发力，这是不对的啊，就是。
爆发力是演员。
很简单就做到的一个事情，就是这很基础。
他只要天性打开了，它它完全可以爆出来，它完全可以覆盖很大的一个值。就像这么说啊，你让演员哭啊，这真的不是什么难事儿，就演员也演哭戏啊。
都不是什么难事儿。
那个那个像我们以前。
你像陈赫，陈赫算是喜这是喜剧演员，对吧？陈赫演哭戏，那也是321歘就来了，一点问题都没有，更不用说女演员。
演员那更没问题。
这点爆发力大家都有。
控制力是什么呢？控制力就是他他表演到什么程度。
这个不是演员自己的事儿，这个是你。
导演。
的要求。
如果一个演员演出来的系数。
显得很松，但是这个戏本身是要一个很紧的气氛，那是你导演的要求没到位啊，你导演应该戏里有这个。
全局观有这个把控。
所以说一般演员的演技都是足够的。
都是足够的。
个别当然有个别演员完全不会演戏啊，有那样的明星啊，那不叫演员，叫明星。
你你不知道吗？
你干嘛要用它？
对吧或者你用那时候没做好思想准备吗？
所以说。
因为演员是跟观众沟通的。
最直接的。
所以观众会觉得哎呀太尴尬了，然后骂演员，我觉得这个大可不必啊，没有必要骂演员。因为。
一个戏的品质绝对不是他们。
如果他只是演员。
绝对不是他们决定的。
所以这个。
关于演技我们要清醒的认识啊，就是。
呃演技当然也有巅峰演技很好的。我只是说大部分的演员觉得够用，对于拍戏来说够用。他但是他演不出那是什么？比如说像李雪健老师那种。
那个那个经典的那个去火车站送人，然后那个人没走，离取站老是看到他了。
就是。
抬头看着他又。
高兴又感动。
咧着嘴哭。
那种戏那个就是那叫演技，对不对？那叫演。
还有一场戏我也觉得是最难。
但不是在也志作品里面。
你我不知道你们记不记得啊，几年前有个视频。
一个农民工。
滞留。
火车站买不到票。
然后呢呃也没地方去，也没地方住，也没钱吃饭。
然后被记者发现了，然后车站的工作人员发现他了，然后给了他一个地方安置他，还给他。
给他东西吃。
问他呃，吃没吃饭。
然后那个农民工说了一句话，那个农民工因为很开心，有人能帮他，所以他咧着嘴说的。
他笑着对呃。
乘务员说说，反正晚上也不干活。
吃不吃饭都可以。
呃不怕你们笑。
因为有点河北河南口音啊，就说不怕你们笑。
是吧。
因为晚上不干活，所以吃不吃饭都可以。
他说这句话的时候啊。
是笑着说的，但是眼睛里面有泪水，但是他又怕。
你看这种台词为什么牛逼啊？他说不怕你们笑。
但是他最怕的就是你们笑。
所以他当时他的脸嘴在笑。
但是心在哭。
眼睛呢又要盯着你。
怕你笑的人，他眼睛会盯着你看。
所以他眼睛努力的盯着你，导致他的。
整个表情。
可大家可以把那个视频找出来啊，那个后期的同学把那个视频找出来。
大家看一下那个表情。
你能把那个演出来，我算进牛。
哎哎，我们同学啊对演戏有兴趣的啊，自己对着镜子啊，或者自己对着手机把这三句台词说一下，具体我不太记得了啊，后期同学把这段放一下，行啊。
别。
大概说的就是。
呃呃不干活的时候，晚饭吃不吃都可以的。
不怕你们笑。
他是笑着说的，他眼睛盯着。
这场戏这种演技你能演出。
你发给我，我算你牛逼。
嘿呵呵呵呵呵。
大家可以练一练啊，我觉得很好玩。
呃，话说回来就是正常的爆发。你像。
啥叫爆爸，拿筋刀？
早年看那个琼瑶戏的时候马景涛。
我受不了了啊，我整个人都快崩溃了，就在那喊哭，呼天抢地，那就是爆发力。
那没啥用那没啥用。
你知道吧？大部分都够了都够了，关键是控制力控制力呢也不能怪。
你控制在什么档次？
这是你导演要求呀，表演到什么程度跟这个戏更搭，跟这个戏的氛围更合，整体更协调，是你导演的要求。
所以说这个这个关于演技啊，我们就不要去讨论了。我们就从。
故事角度。
那说回战国，就是这个战国，现在就是这么一个故事结构，拍的呢很不好。
我们怎么去解决问题？
首先我教大家衡量一个片子，衡量一个剧本，衡量一个故事。
呃，做的好不好？
或者是好与不好，从哪方面哪些方面下手。
我先跟大家说一下。
一个片子好与不好，我们从四个方面看。
一。
这个结构。
就是故事结构啊。
第一第二。
元素。
就是看点和元素，看点和元素。
第三。
情感。
第四。
情绪。
从这四个方面去衡量一个故事，或者衡量一个。
成品。
有没有做好？
我们也可以从这四个方面去检查我们这个片子为什么垮。
好吧。
结构就是故事结构。
这个片子的故事结构。
我刚才说了爱情呀。
爱情点。
爱情片的结构。
是啥来着？
简单说啊。
互补和。
互补和沟壑。
对吧。
互补与沟壑。
孙膑和田曦互补吗？
基本不互补。
你孙膑很聪明，有计谋。
前玺也不是傻子呀。
两人完全没有到互相需要的那种程度。
没有到互相离不开的。
基本上不形成互补。
甚至两人并肩作战都很少。
你如果说是一个是将女将军，一个是男军师，两人并肩作战，无坚不摧，谁也离不开谁一离开的话就打败仗，那也行。
文武吗？文武互补嘛？那也行。
他其实没用，都没交代。
完全没有交代两个人的互补。
两个人呢不可或缺。
然后沟壑呢。
这个片子勾壑是有的。
就是他有一点，但是太。
你看啊他俩人在一块都有过哪些沟壑啊？
秦王算一个。
他们都是齐国人嘛。
他们都是齐国人啊齐国人。
齐王要娶前夕，那一国之君呢？
一国之君要娶前夕，那显然是你俩爱情的巨大沟壑啊，这是皇上的女人。
这是皇上的女儿，大王的女儿。
这显然是沟壑。但是呢。
给的太小，太晚，就是通篇也没有看出齐王要娶迁夕。
在最后的时候，突然天西说我要嫁给大王了，然后孙膑说，那你就去嘛。
然后呢，他就嫁给大王了。然后这个齐王呢并没有说我要霸占田西，不给孙膑齐王来这一看。
你怎么不高兴了，你是不是喜欢孙膑？
这样吧，我把你赐给孙膑吧。
他又走了。
等于齐王这个沟壑啊完全没做，没有用，跟闹着玩似的。
如果你要用这个勾壑，你要上来就前西，就是齐王的人齐王的人。
就只不过还没完婚，比如说没到岁数啊，或者没到吉日。
那么你你这段恋情本身就是对吧？
就是就是做着一件没有结果的爱情。我们说一个电影故事很多的时候。
大家看的是什么啊？就基本看点是m impossible。
不可能完成的任务。那你这个爱情就是注定不可能完成的。
刚才手机内存满了啊，要重新开始重新说啊就是。
刚才说的是这个孙膑和田西这个爱情。
之间的沟壑问题，对吧？必须得是让观众觉得这个爱情成不了。
但是人家就爱啊，就飞蛾扑火啊，就爱。
这才是爱情片嘛，爱情片的真谛就是这个嘛。
所以说这个你看这个勾壑。
我们说这个沟壑啊，它其实还有一个潜在沟壑，就是田忌。
就是女方的父亲啊，这个也是常用的呀，家庭原因不同意嘛。
对不对？
前进。
但是田忌成为他俩爱情沟壑啊，也基本没用。
前一直没有表态。
没有反对呀，就是最后有一下突然田忌拿刀。
抵着孙膑，然后孙膑也说，其实我早知道你是内奸，就他是齐国的内奸。
然后。
孙膑说，但我劝你别做哪家。
然后田忌说，好吧，把刀放下。
田忌成为他俩爱情的沟壑，总共不超过5秒。
又很草率的就解决了。
所以这个沟壑啊既不深，然后又很松散，导致这段爱情没有沟。我刚才说了，这段爱情首先不互补，就是这两人不相爱，你明白我意思吗？互补的意思不一定说一个是残缺一个零件，就一定要那么去卡，对吧？一个嗜杀，比如说那个那个。
景甜这个角色就是田心是个女将军嘛，她就是就是嗜血成狂。
但是呢孙膑比如说晕血不上战场，对吧？看到人死了就受不了，看到小鸡儿死了也受不了。
不一定非得是这种互补，你完全会做他俩个相爱嘛。
就他俩的。
相知相爱，你也没做出来。
顺便怎么爱上天西的？
孙膑远远的看到，哎，那个女将宾是谁？好漂亮啊，眼睛好大呀，我爱。
就爱上了。
就爱上了，所以两个人的爱情做的非常草率。
没有相爱的过程，没有相爱相知的过程。
我曾经在课上说过，我说过爱情片，我不擅长。
我不擅长。
但我即便再不擅长，我也可以给大家。
讲点招，一般爱情片怎么做啊？首先一定要做渊源。
就这两个人不能是简单的。
一看哇，眼睛好漂亮，我爱他。
你以为去蹦迪呢？
女蹦迪出五池里撩菜呢。
他得有渊源。
一般来说啊，比如说小时候认识。
或者之前有过什么样的一个。
前史故事。
对吧天作之合嘛。
小时候有婚约，或者是曾经小时候有个约定，为什么都喜欢做小时候约定？因为你想要感动人啊。
什么东西感动人？
什么东西能让你哭？同学们。
弱小的东。
弱小的东西最容易让你管感动。
弱小的东西还坚持，那就更敢。
你知道吗？呃，两个大大人，1个25，1个23说我爱你，我要爱你一生一世，你根本就不哭。
你根本就不哭。
对吧。
因为他俩不弱小。
但是如果两个小孩，一个8岁，1个7岁，两个人是邻居，从小一块长大。
俩人天天一块玩，一块去山上抓蚂蚱，一块去隔壁村看。
看唱戏的。
现在一个小孩要搬家。
我搬去别的村了。
然后另外一个小孩就。
跟他约定。
长大了要娶他。
你就会很感动，为什么？
因为他弱小。
因为这个承诺很弱小，弱不禁风，但他们很坚持，很认真，你就容易感。
对不对？
然后等到怎么样更感动呢？
就这两个七八岁一个一个小男孩，一个小女孩约定。
这小男孩说长大我要群。
一个人守了承诺，一个人没守。
小女孩一直在等着这一天，等到自己长成18岁的那一天，她长成18岁的时候，男孩已经19岁了。
然后他觉得18岁了，他可以出去了，他告别父母跋山涉水，去到那个小男孩搬家去的那个县那个乡。
去那一看。
你看小男孩19岁，今天正在娶媳妇。
正在结婚。
我们这个18岁的小姑娘。
守了11年的一个。
美好的愿望承诺。
就站在这个婚礼迎亲的队伍。
外面。
当然没有人能认出他。
你会不敢弄吗？这场。
这个18岁的女孩站在那儿。
他也没有去打扰，他也没有去闹。
他就想看看。
他娶了谁？
你不敢弄。
这弱手。
热小的承度。
是一种方。
还有一种方法。
就我们就岔开来啊说一下爱情吧。
岔开来说一下关于爱情啊。
这是第一种，就是有有两个人有渊源，对吧？有承诺或者是叫。
有先天的一个预设，有一个预设，对吧？两人要在一块，这种是是是是一种方法。然后第二种方法呢？
第二种方法呢。
就是。
互相牺牲。
就这俩人相识之后吧，我为了你扛了一个什么事儿，我帮你了。
遭到了我家里的人。
一些一些。
不满杀害了我的家族里，然后呢，你又头条报里又帮了我一件什么事儿。
一般如果要迅速做爱情，做互相牺牲也是常用套路，而且互相牺牲往往就能对应上那个互补呀。
就是我擅长的，你不擅长，你擅长的，我不擅长。
做互相牺牲。
对吧这就是一种套路。然后第三种套路啊，比如说共谋。
共谋啊共谋。
我没有合。
共谋也是经常做的呀。比如说你看现在的爱情片，特别是美国的爱情片。
少男少女刚刚相遇。
往往要干一个什么事儿啊？
冲去有钱人家里的大别墅，跳进人家游泳池里游个泳。
为啥？
因为在美国文化里面。
私闯民宅是重罪啊，美国人私闯民宅，你都可以拿枪崩了他。
他们为什么要让这少男少女去犯最重的罪呢？
就是。
共谋呀。
让您的男女主角共谋做一件。
坏事儿。
也是叙述情感升温的一个。
明白这意思吧。
所以说。
塑造爱情啊。
还是有很多办法的。
你既然是个爱情人，你现在把他俩相爱做出来吧。
然后你拉钩的时候，我们才心疼了。
我们才会觉得哎呀怎么有情人不能成为眷属，我们才会难受吗？这不就是爱情片。
结构上的征谛嘛。
先做相爱，然后再分开嘛。
从结构的角度就有片子。
没做好。
这就是结构角度。
然后我们说元素和看点。
啥叫元素和看点？
这四个层面是你衡量你一个作品。
是否优秀？
适合好的四个方面。我们说第一个方面结构上来说啊，百分之百。
归编剧管。
就是说这个是我们百分之百掌掌控的。所以我们在课上讲这个讲的也最多，这个我们百分之百掌控。
元素和看点呢我们能掌握个一半以上吧。
我们掌握70%，比如说啊这个能掌握百分之百，这个我们掌握70%。啥叫元素看点？就是一个片子啊，它有很多看点，很多东西很吸引人。
这也很重要。
比如说啊就说这个片子。
他可以有一些什么样的看点？
你打眼一想，比如说。
他会有很多历史风貌的看点吧。
战国的人吃什么穿什么开什么车啊，不叫开这骑驾什么车，然后呢。
休闲娱乐什么？
然后战国的时候的君臣关系是什么样的，怎么上朝，怎么琢磨事儿，武器兵器还打仗吗？
这些就是历史方面的看点。
对不对？
对吧。
然后我们说孙膑是军事家，鬼谷子的学生传的神神叨叨的，对吧？在历史上传的神神叨叨的。
那他会有很多奇谋吧。
智慧型的看点吧。
就是孙膑又想到一个什么办法，解决一个什么问题，就是这题谋也是他的看点吧。
另外呢它是爱情片，那我们得有。
浪漫方面的看点吧。
比如说拥文戏，比如说两个人的。
打闹戏对吧？比如说两个人很唯美的镜头的戏，两个人谈心的戏，对吧？或者是。
这个初吻第一次拉手，还是这个这个这个第一次心动这些浪漫元素。
也得有吧。
也得有吧。另外，作为一个。
有很多阴谋，又有很多血腥的这个这这样的一个年代的戏。
这种。
危机。
悬疑。
别还有悬疑。
悬念吧疑好难写啊，悬疑方面的这些看点也得有吧。
谁是间谍，谁要厮杀谁，这些悬疑看点也得有吧。
所以说你看啊这是从元素和看点上。
编剧能解决70%，当然有很多元素。
那是导演设计啊，演员设计或者是服装道具。
场景制片去设计。
这对一个片子也很重要。我们说结构相当于树干，那元素看点相当于是就是树上的果实。
相对于树上的果实呀。
也很重要。
也没做好。
也没做好。然后第三就是情感。
情感。
情感是啥呢？
就是。
你一个片子。
好不好看？
从情感方面就是。
你观众入没入戏，观众有没有走进角色的世界？
感受到爱情或者感受到父女情，或者感受到君臣情，或者感受到兄弟情。
这些情感你有没有做出来？
我们说我们说情感啊是跟着人物走的对吧？跟着人物走的那你就看你的人设扎不扎实。
人物那节课我专门讲过人物可怜可性可爱，对吧？人物的技能和缺陷这些设定。
你去看吧。
我们先就从最简单一个角度，从救猫咪的角度。
孙膑有叫猫咪。
他救了那个。
徐娇演的那个角色，徐娇演了一个小孩，所以我说这个戏卡斯有多强？徐娇在里面就一场戏。
一个路边小孩，顺膑把他救了。
顺便把它救。
有救猫咪，但是前夕就没有，而且前夕做的是反的。
田西的出场是在战场上拼杀。
拼完之后打了胜仗，俘虏了一排魏国士兵，然后那一排魏国士兵排着被砍头。
就是齐国士兵把魏国士兵俘虏了之后，跪了一排，然后排着砍头。
杀战俘本来就是一件很残忍的事情，对吧？不道义的事情。
然后呢，在那一个一个砍头，但是在士兵在那砍。这时候，我们的女主角田西很威武的走了过来，我以为他要拦住这种行为。
说一句放他们回去，对吧？或者是呃那个卸了他们的呃武器呃，流放他们之类的。
没想到他过来拔起自己的剑，他也跟着砍了一个，就是你们砍我也过来砍一个。
很没有必要的一场戏嘛。
很伤角色的，你干什么呀，对不对？展现你。
会砍。
俘虏刀法狠，因为前面每个人都在砍呀，你显不出你什么特别，你这这场戏有什么意义？
旧猫咪也没做，然后可怜可亲可爱都没做技能缺陷做的都不好。
都不好，按道理讲，孙膑是完全可以做技能的。
孙膑是个奇才，是完全可以做一个很很很可视化的很。
很很好用的技能。
然后它的缺陷也可以做的。
明显，但是呢又很可爱。我们现在他这个孙膑做的切线直接是傻白甜。
就是天真看起来就像傻子。
这要做的这样一个缺陷。
但是你做这种缺陷，你就更增加。
一个什么难度呢？就是田夕为什么爱他。
一点爱他的道理都没有，你知道吗？
所以说这个从情感的角度来讲。
主要是因为人物的设定。
技能和缺陷啊，或者是可怜可性可爱呀，没做好。
然后第四个方面是情绪。
我们说情绪啊，假设情感啊。
我们根据也占70%的控制力。
你毕竟还要还要有那个那个那个那个演员表演嘛。
情绪。
我们编剧可能控制的只能到50%或者40%吧，控制不到一半。
但是也很重要，我们也要重视，就是什么叫情绪？情绪跟情感不一样啊，情感啊情感是爱呀、恨呀，对吧？
呃，牺牲奉献啊那种那叫情感情绪是什么？比如说紧张。
一般的片子会制造紧张感。
然后或者是。
害怕。
或者是感动啊，悲伤了，你跟着悲伤呗。所以你看啊很多片子啊，他如果前面几样都不强啊都一般，但是他情绪做的好，就是说最后煽情行啊，很多电影喜欢这么搞，就你走出电影院的时候刚哭完，然后你就说得这片段还行，他就最后给你玩情绪让你哭。
这个也是一个很好用的招，很赖啊，但是也很好用，就你得定要动情绪啊。
你让观众紧张，一直揪着心，那你这个片子也赢了，算你牛逼，你要观众一直难过，那你牛逼。
你让观众一直笑也很牛逼。
就情绪你能调动起来这个片子。
也是一个很好的。
保障。
这么说吧。
所以你看啊从这四个方面，我们说。
如果都能做好，这个片子就好。
但是在咱们这个片子里面。
结构首先。
基本落怕了。
基本没有。
然后呢，元素和看点。
我认为也不及格。
也没有展现奇怪，因为古装片、战争片。
是很好，我给大家举个例子，有有个。
好莱坞电影前几年叫狂怒。
布拉德皮特也。
那个剧本的故事结构。
其实就一般。
但是他的元素特别好，就是他把战争场面还原的特别的真实。
就是能种听声音判断对方是什么炮弹。
那种。
声音的那种真实性，战场的那种。
真实感战对他们对战争拍的非常专业就是。
这个看点元素支撑那个片子。
大家就不太会去。
吐槽他。
其他方面啊。
这就是探点元素，你如果拍的很好。
呃，m max。
我还又举这个例子了，m max它就是给你看。
他那个风格呀那个废土风格呀。
他他他哪有什么故事结构。
情感也基本没有。
他就是给你看元素看点，然后调动你的情绪。这两招。
这两根就拿下了，就把我们拿下了。
所以说这四个啊，你当然尽量是要都做好。
但是呢。
其实是有可可以有所侧重的啊。
那后咱这个战国呢。
这个。
元素看点。
也是做的很一般。
情感。
完全歇彩。
情绪完全没有，就是从头到尾没有调动情绪。
没有调动情绪，其实完全是可以的。因为比如说啊田忌的叛变完全可以做一条大悬一线嘛。
然后齐王到底什么心思？魏王到底什么心思？更可怕的就是对手这个庞涓完全可以做出威胁来嘛，调动你的情绪嘛。
调动你的情绪嘛。
所以说就是从这四个方面。
从这四个方面。
我们来我们就能认识到这个片子他到底掉链子掉在哪。
然后再讲几句什么呢？
如果。
这个片子。
让咱们来写。
咱们怎么弄？
就构建这个故事啊，如果重新来过的话。
我们怎么做？
我也有几点设想跟大家分享一下。
就是这个片子这个任务。
这个项目当时如果交给咱了。
咱们怎么写？
首先。
如果。
甲方。
一定要锚定爱情片的话。
一定要毛定爱情片的。
我认为这个片子。
应该做。
孙膑。
我。
好晚的爱情。
因为爱情本身就是虚构的嘛，对吧？
我们这个就不用说什么历史史实到底是什么样。
孙膑和跑婉就是金喜善这个角色。
和。
孙膑。
这对爱情才是最好做的。
而且戏女唐婉也很帮着孙膑的。
当然很莫名其妙帮着他在这个战国里面是很莫名其妙的，他明明是庞涓的妹妹，你亲哥哎。
这个人跟你有什么关系啊？然后他为了阻止哥哥杀他去给大牢里给他送钥匙。
当然了，你可以解释，因为他俩是闺蜜，那是我闺蜜的准男朋友啊，但是这他妈是你哥呀。
你背叛你哥去帮你闺蜜的准男友。
而且更夸张的是什么呢？他哥最后要跟他决战的时候，他为了阻止他哥跟他决战。
他自焚了。
他放了一把火，不他不光自焚，他放了一把火，把他哥所有的粮草全给烧了，让他哥打不成这个仗。
然后他自己也走进那个。
粮草堆里活活烧死。
我反正不会为了我闺蜜做这个事儿的。
不到这个程度是吧？
真的不到那个程度，就是这个事儿太。
如果要做爱情啊，我推荐做孙膑和傍婉的爱情，为什么呢？
首先。
有先天的敌对关系，因为孙膑最大的敌人说到底还是庞涓。
不是齐王，也不是田忌，你硬做齐王跟田忌没有意义，你们都是齐国人，都是一头的，战略上是一伙的。
对不对啊？
所以很难做。
你干嘛不说跟跑晚呢？
陶宛是你死对头的妹妹，她如果跟你，而且你俩还是同学，你俩从小就认识，是同学。
他跟孙唐涓都是鬼鬼谷子的学生嘛，你俩从小是同学，所以你俩小时候也认识你同学的妹妹，小时候跟你也认识，这不很正常吗？有前十有渊源了吧，有情愫有约定了吧。然后长大之后各为其主，你回齐国，他回魏国，但是这段感情没放下，你如果硬要做爱情片。
你应该做生命。
好晚来次。
更好做，阻力先天的就是我哥呀。
好这个角色也更有张力啊。
当然了，你如果说哎我们是主要是为了做景甜，那你让景田也抛啊。
是不是啊？
就是来一边是我哥，一边是我男人，我怎么抉择？
对不对？一边是爱情，一边是国家利益，你怎么抉择？
对不对？然后我做抉择的时候，比如说。
我开始帮着我哥，我以为我哥。
对吧只是。
呃也不是坏人，结果我哥把孙命的。
毁育费。
对吧后来我去帮孙膑，但是我去帮孙膑呢，连齐国人也不接受我呀。齐国人会说，这是魏国庞涓的妹妹开什么玩笑，怎么能来我们齐国呢？
你看这不就好做了吗？
是不是好做的？这个这段爱情不就。
既有渊源，又又有阻力了嘛？
又有阻力了嘛，而且他作为旁圈的妹妹。
是标准的一个叫中间人啊。
它是夹心饼干啊，它夹在中间。
你看他比前夕的位置好多少，前夕前继来，他爹爷跟孙膑是同事。
是吧然后呢，齐王跟孙膑两个人他是国君，他是国师。
很仰让他。
他能跟你抢媳妇儿。
奇蛙也太真是没见过世面了，对不对？
你跟你的国师抢媳妇儿啊。
你差媳妇还是咋的？
是不是就是这些利益都没有针锋相对。
所以很难做，为了做田忌跟孙膑的都都都不惜说田忌是叛徒，说田忌是间谍。
但是你你也就是说了5秒钟吧。
所以说。
如果毛定是爱情片，非要做爱情片。
顺便。
绝对是不二选择。
不信大家试着写一写。
你把战国的故事看一看，听我的写孙膑跟庞婉的爱情故事。
当然了，这是非要做爱情片的话啊，这是非要做爱情。
如果没有要求做爱情片。
如果没有要求做爱情片，那这个片子最好的选择其实是做兄弟情。
做兄弟去。
孙膑和庞涓。
他俩才是双男主做这一对才最好做两兄弟师出同门，但是呢分别是两个国家。回到各自的国家之后呢，各自都做同样的工作，就是搞谋略嘛。然后呢，庞涓嫉妒孙膑。
孙膑呢信任庞涓，他呢骗他，然后。
废了他的腿，然后呢，他又开始去报复他，这不标准的相爱相杀吗？
这不标准的兄弟情吗？这种片子做这个路线的话，就可以做高然路线。
就是热水片做高燃路线。
两个人之前是什么样的兄弟，对吧？然后呢，为了各自的利益，开始呢是有点记格，但是呢主要还是合作是然后其中一个人逐渐黑化。
就旁见黑化，但是具体是怎么黑化呢？是他人品低下吗？其实也不一定是也可能是误会嘛。
也可能是误会嘛。
也可能是局势所迫嘛。
就是两个兄弟各为其主。最后。
走向了。
互相残杀的境地。
这种片子不好看吗？
做一个。
热血片儿。
完全可以做出来呀。
说孙膑庞涓呀。
这个说说男主啊，就忽略井钱这个因素啊。
我们做双男主呀，应该。
这是才是最好的选择。这个片子的。
结构写法。
两个同学。
同门师兄。
师傅更偏爱孙膑，兵法给了他了呀。
对吧兵法给了他了呀。
他就记住嘛。
但是记住吗？
完全可以做兄弟情吗。
当然还有第三种方法。
比如说你要不我们不想做爱情，也不想做兄弟情。我们其实就想做。
比较。
个人传记的比较沉重的。
历史的那种。
那种片子的那种感觉，比较宏大的那种感觉。
因为这种不管是做兄弟情，做爱情，这都是以情为主嘛。我们想做以以史为主，以历史为主。
那你就可以做金羊毛嘛。
用孙膑复仇。
为。
用复仇为主事件。
做金羊毛类型的。
就是孙膑要复仇。
上来激励事件就是庞涓把孙膑的。
腿废了，然后孙膑逃回齐国。
做齐国的国师。
准备复仇。
爆仇片。
那就是。
料子就可以沉一点，沉重一些。
顺便。
如何？
一步一步。
战胜庞涓。
但是最后其实战胜的是自己。
对吧如何报仇其实是化解自己心中的仇。
如何从？
报仇这个。
小目标。
演化为。
拯救天下苍生，这是大目标。从小E到大义的这么一个人弧线，就是把我们把。
把主要目标。
因因为设定成金羊毛的故事的话，人物弧线就可以做的。
跨度很大，很完整。
调子呢就比较沉。
其实就是讲孙膑的。
蜕变与成长。
从这个角度。
做复仇片。
也不是不可以。
也能做成不错的东西。
也能做出不错的。
所以说。
如果这个任务当时交给我们。
或者是现在交给我们吧。
战国这个题材，你就根据这些人物，根据他现有的这个片子，这些给给你的信息，你重新构建这三个方向，大家可以试一试嘛。
大家可以试一试闲一写。
写一写故事，写一写大纲。如果要写爱情，写孙膑唐婉呃，孙膑唐婉。
如果写兄弟情。
那就是热血片，写孙膑庞涓。
如果写金羊毛，那就是复仇主题。
孙膑。
的复仇。
如何从。
手刃对手到化解心中仇恨，如何从报私仇到拯救天下苍生？
做一个完整的融弧线都可以。
好吧。
这节课我们就说这么多吧，啰里八嗦也说不少。大家从这三个方向。
自己挑一个，自己写一写。记得我说的啊，这节课最重要内容其实是一般毛定这个事儿啊。
别老毛定自己比别人牛逼。
千万不要这样。
那这不好。
好吧，这不好。
就是。
大家都是一般人。
犯的都是一般的错对吧？拍的都是一般的片。
但是你如果想拍好呢，那你就得努力，你就得付出不一般的努力。所以做一般人的设定是为了让我大家付出不一般的努力。
才能做成个事情，才能做好事情。
今天虽然讲的是烂片，但是绝对没有。
讽刺别人的意思，也没有诋毁别人的意思。
我们从里面学点东西，因为你如果不学的话，你拍出来。
也是这样的片子，搞不好还不如这样。
这一课这个作业就就就就是这个吧，大家自己练一练。
根据我指的这个三个方向，或者你自己再能找到方向也可以哈，你自己再能找到方向也可以。
先写个呃故事梗待吧。
大家试着练一练。
下课吧。